this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later in the video
hey 42 here when you think of a classic
prison escape you might picture a
desperate inmate feverishly filing away
at the bars of his cell window a
spotlight sweeping across a prison yard
as a few daring criminals clamber over a
prison wall or maybe even an improbably
long tunnel hidden behind a poster of a
1940s film icon
one thing that's a little less likely to
spring to mind is a steaming hot bowl of
traditional miso soup but miso soup is
exactly what japanese anti-hero yoshi
shiratori used to escape the formidable
abhishari prison
intrigued
you should be
because this soup based breakout was
just one of
[Music]
four
yes
successful prison escapes
between 1936 and 1947
each of which was more ingenious than
the last
i want to take a moment to talk about
hair loss because i've had people close
to me start to lose their hair as early
as their 20s and it's always been a
really upsetting experience if you're in
the same boat then you're not alone did
you know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left you used to have to
go to the doctor's office for a hair
loss prescription but now thanks to
keeps you can visit an online doctor and
get the treatment you need delivered
directly to your door i like keeps
because it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
there's a reason that keeps has more
five star reviews in any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trusts them for their hair loss
prevention medication if you're like me
you're probably not ready to lose your
hair just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash 40t
or click the link in the description
below to receive 50
off your first order don't miss out
yoshi shiratori was born in the tohaku
region of japan in 1907 towards the end
of the meiji era a period in japanese
history that brought with it a series of
major political economic and social
changes
japan was a country torn between the
draw of modernity and the stability of
tradition
but one thing still firmly rooted in the
past was the legal system
jail sentences were long and prisons
were unforgiving
violent places to be avoided at all
costs
at first shiratori did a pretty good job
of doing just that he lived a simple
life working in a tofu shop
then later as a crab fisherman
but like many yoshi shiratori dreamt of
the finer things in life
the problem was without a proper
education he found himself with very
little opportunity to better himself
eventually he felt the pull of gambling
and petty crime
and his life became one giant downward
spiral
that would finally lead to him being
accused of murder
shivatori always maintained his
innocence insisting he'd been framed by
a gang of local criminals
and that's a confession he'd made was
coerced by corrupt police officers
but despite his protests he was found
guilty and sent to a mori prison to
await sentencing
he now faced a very real possibility
that he might be put to death for a
murder he claims to not have committed
but yoshi shiratori was not the kind of
person to sit around twiddling his
thumbs whilst awaiting the grim reaper's
arrival and from the second he walked
through the amore prison gates shivatori
was on the lookout for an opportunity to
escape
as it happened he didn't have to wait
all that long
shimatori's daily routine mostly
consisted of counting the cracks on his
ceiling whilst avoiding the regular
beatings dished out by the prison guards
to put it bluntly life was grim
but one of the few things the prisoners
had to look forward to was a visit to
the bathhouse which might conjure up
images of a lovely roman spa with marble
fountains and luxurious steam rooms but
that couldn't be further from the truth
in fact for the inmates of amory prison
bath time quite literally meant being
given a bucket of water but it was in
one of these buckets that shiratori
found something that changed his
fortunes
and set him on the road to infamy
that something
was a short metal wire
not much to look at
but in the hands of yoshi shiratori who
just so happened to be a master lock
picker
it was a skeleton key capable of opening
any door
after smuggling the wire back to his
cell he bided his time waiting for the
perfect moment to slip away unnoticed
and since he'd been studying the guard's
patrol patterns for months at this point
he knew exactly when that perfect moment
would come
the plan worked like a charm
and before he knew it
yoshi shiratori was free
unfortunately that freedom was
short-lived
after just three days on the run
shiratori was caught trying to steal
supplies from a local hospital
people don't tend to look too kindly on
escaped convicts who steal from the sick
and infirm so once again he was arrested
and this time he was packed off to akita
prison on the plus side he arrived at
his new home to the news that he'd
managed to evade the death penalty which
meant he had plenty of time to enjoy the
misery of life behind bars
unsurprisingly japan's answer to harry
houdini wasn't planning on tolerating
incarceration for very long this time
shiratori had no way of picking the
locks
but that didn't matter something else
had caught his eye a skylight was set
into the ceiling of his cell
that might sound like a bit of an
oversight from a prison planning
perspective
except reaching this particular skylight
was near enough impossible not only were
the ceilings extremely high and the
skylight securely barred
but the cell walls were smooth offering
very little in the way of grip
but unlike us mere mortals shiratori
possessed a kind of climbing ability
that spiderman himself would be proud of
as soon as the coast was clear he
shimmied up to the skylight to take a
closer look
to his delight he discovered the screws
that held it in place were rusted and
the fittings were loose
still it took him several weeks of
scaling the walls
night after night to work the skylight
free from the ceiling
eventually he was able to remove the
frame and after serving just three
months of his life sentence
shiratori was free again and this time
he had a plan he hoped would prevent him
from ever having to return to jail
you see during his time at akita
shiratori had struck up an unlikely
friendship with a prison guard named
kabayashi kobayashi had always refused
to partake in any violence aimed towards
shiratori
and over time shiratori had come to
consider the god an ally
perhaps even a friend
as a result he believed kabayashi held
the key to his freedom
if a well-respected man of law could
back up his pleas of innocence he would
stand a much better chance of having a
conviction overturned and with that in
mind the recently escaped shiratori
decided to pay his one-time guard a
visit
but things didn't quite go the way
shiratori had imagined
although were somewhat startled
kabayashi welcomed his former prisoner
into his home and listened very keenly
to the plan
the second shiratori excused himself to
use the bathroom
kabayashi grassed him up the fugitive
barely had time to finish doing his
business before he was once again at the
mercy of the japanese legal system
unsurprisingly the authorities were
starting to get a little bit annoyed
with shiratori at this point the
insufferable convict simply wouldn't
stay wherever they put him
so this time they decided there was only
one thing for it shiratori was sent to
japan's answer to alcatraz
the infamous abhishiri prison
the fishing village of abbashiri had
remained relatively unchanged for
hundreds of years until the arrival of a
meiji government official towards the
end of the 19th century the official was
awestruck by the vast unforgiving
wilderness and the large icy lakes that
surrounded the area and he quickly
realized that this desolate village
would make the perfect location for an
inescapable prison
well almost inescapable
the prison was built by convicts who
were quite literally forced to construct
the very cells
where they'd then live out the rest of
their miserable lives
as the prison took shape many of the
prisoners died from exhaustion and
malnutrition and some were even attacked
by the bears and wolves that lived in
the surrounding wilderness
anyone who was caught trying to escape
this living hell
was beheaded on the spot
abhishiri was a prison forged from pain
and suffering
a theme that will continue long after
its completion in 1890
and give rise to its reputation as
perhaps
the most feared institution in the whole
of japan
in order to hold on to this proud
reputation extra precautions were made
for shiratori's arrival
his hands and legs were bound by iron
manacles that had been constructed
without a keyhole and could only be
removed by a blacksmith
and this time there was no skylight in
his cell meaning his only glimpse of the
outside world beyond his four walls
came when his meals were pushed through
the food hatch in his cell door
now imagine for a moment that you're an
inmate at abbashiri prison you've
probably had a long day being used as a
punchback
your cell is damp and cold and it's more
than likely you haven't eaten for a very
long time just then the food hatch opens
and a lovely steaming bowl of soup
appears before your eyes
what would you do next
i imagine nearly all of you would have
slurped down that bowl of soup before
i'd even finished this sentence
but not sure tori
you see he knew that as well as
containing stock miso paste and the
occasional vegetable or two
miso soup is extremely salty
and if there's one thing that salty
liquids are good at it's slowly reducing
anything made of iron to a pile of rust
over the course of six months shivatori
began sharing his daily portion of soup
with both his manacles
and with the frame surrounding the food
hatch
as expected slowly but surely the iron
began to rust
until eventually shiratori was able to
free himself of his restraints and took
the feeding hatch out of its frame in
the door
but there was a problem even with the
frame removed the feeding hatch was far
too small to serve as an escape route
or at least that's what the abbasiri
guards assumed
as it turned out shiratori had yet
another trick up his sleeve
quite literally you see aside from a
scheming mind and an almost inhuman
ability to resist the steamy charms of
miso soup
shiratori was able to dislocate his
shoulders at will
and so
he waited until the coast was clear
removed his manacles
slipped the frame off the feeding hatch
popped his shoulders out of their
sockets and like a master contortionist
he squeezed himself with a tiny hole in
the door and made a bid for freedom in
doing so he became the first and only
person ever to escape from abbashiri
prison
which is pretty remarkable considering
it's been in operation for over 130
years
but this time the escape came with dire
consequences
for those of you who aren't intimately
familiar with the japanese penal system
abhishiri is located in northern
hokkaido one of the coldest parts of
japan
and without anywhere to go shivatori
headed for the only place he knew he
could be free of the japanese legal
system
the wild mountains to the north
he soon found a cave and began foraging
and hunting for food
but living in a cave in the mountains
was only ever going to be a temporary
solution and after two years alone in
the wilderness
it was time for yoshi shiratori to
re-enter society
unfortunately things didn't go quite to
plan away from his trusty foraging spots
shivatori soon became very hungry so
when he came across a field of tomato
plants he went to work stuffing his face
and when the owner of the field turned
up
he found what appeared to be some kind
of feral tomato juice covered human
laying into the crop as though on a
personal mission to destroy every tomato
in japan
an altercation ensued and the farmer
came off worse
much worse actually
he was dead
shiratori was arrested once again and
this time he was given a sentence he had
no chance of escaping
the death sentence
he was sent to sapporo prison to await
his execution
sapporo wasn't quite as intimidating as
his previous home but it did come with
its own set of problems
shivatori was given a specially designed
cell said to be 100 escape proof
which you'd think would be standard
practice for a prison cell but hey i'm
no architect
shiratori was assigned six guards whose
sole purpose was to make sure that the
crafty bugger under their care
stuck around just long enough to be
thoroughly executed
things looked bleaker than ever for
shiratori and over time his confinement
and impending execution caused him to
sink into a deep depression
he began spending most of his time in
bed the guards noted that on the rare
occasions he did get up he would pace
around his cell staring at the ceiling
as though desperately trying to
formulate another one of his trademark
escapes
but the powers that be in the japanese
prison system had learnt from their
mistakes
there was no skylight to climb out of no
locks to pick and no food slots to
squeeze through
it appeared that shiratori
had finally met his match
well at least that's what the guards
thought right up until the moment they
discovered that his cell was empty
[Music]
you see every action shiratori had taken
since arriving at the prison staring at
the ceiling pacing around his cell
lying in bed as though he'd given up all
hope
all of it had been carefully designed to
distract the gods from his real plan
every night when the prison was in
darkness
shiratori had been secretly digging a
good old-fashioned tunnel beneath his
bed
like a rebellious teenager sneaking out
to go on a date he'd removed some
floorboards and placed him underneath
his duvet to make it appear as though he
was still in bed
when in reality he was borrowing his way
to freedom below using a trusty miso
soup bowl as an improvised shovel
after escaping shiratori once again
managed to evade capture living as a
fugitive for a year
but this life was beginning to take its
toll now in his 40s shiratori was no
longer a young man he was tired of
running
tired of constantly having to look over
his shoulder
tired of pretending to be someone he
wasn't something needed to change
while shiratori planned his next move he
found himself sitting on a park bench
beside a police officer
most escapees would have run a mile at
this point but chiritory was made of
sterner stuff
after all he'd been doing this stuff for
years he stayed calm and even struck up
a conversation with the policeman
the officer was oblivious to the fact he
was chasing away with one of japan's
most wanted criminals
so much so that he even offered
shiratori a cigarette
now this might not seem like a big deal
but in post-war japan cigarettes were
like gold's dust
shiratori was blown away by the gesture
it was the first time in years he'd been
shown any real compassion by anyone
least of all a representative of the law
he was so moved that he promptly
confessed all to the police officer he
told him the details of his wrongful
conviction and how he'd been subjected
to years of violence at the hands of his
prison guards
he explained the details of his many
escapes and his long battle to clear his
name of the murders attributed to it
the officer listened intently to
shiratori's incredible story a look of
awe and compassion on his face when the
fugitive was finished the police officer
stood up with a smile on his face
and then arrested chirotory on the spot
i mean hey it was his job
but fortunately for shiratori japan had
changed considerably since his first
conviction and he now found himself at
the mercy of a much fairer legal system
his death sentence was revoked on the
grounds that his murder of the tomato
farmer had been in self-defense
not only had shiratori escaped from four
prisons but he'd now escaped from the
executioner as well
of course he was still very much a
criminal and so he was soon back behind
bars for a fifth stint
this time in tokyo's future prison he
would go on to serve 14 years of his
20-year sentence before being released
on good behavior
so far as anyone knows shiratori never
attempted to make one of his trademark
escapes
on release he returned home to his only
surviving family member his daughter
and lived out the rest of his days on
the right side of the tracks
before dying of a heart attack in 1979
at the age of 71.
it's hard to say if the details of
shivatori's remarkable life story have
been embellished over the years the man
came to be something of a legend in his
native country and legends have a habit
of growing with time his story has been
immortalized in novels movies and comic
books and today there's even a memorial
for him inside the notorious abishiri
prison it's rather poetic that a place
that one sought to break yashi
sharatori's spirit
now celebrates him as the ultimate
japanese anti-hero
[Music]
thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break you're welcome